[Music]
in 2009 a mysterious person or persons
who went under the name Satoshi Nakamoto
wrote a piece of software that would
become the foundation for a new kind of
money cryptocurrency for a while
Bitcoin and its brethren was just a
hobby for computer programmers and math
nerds but recently it's drawn the
interest of investors banks and
governments who wonder if it might
actually start competing with
traditional currencies like Dollars and
yen bitcoins been in the news a lot
lately but if you're like most people
you've probably never used it and don't
know exactly what it is but according to
some estimates over 16 million Americans
buy and sell Bitcoin frequently and over
a hundred thousand merchants and vendors
worldwide accept it as a payment but is
that enough to qualify as a currency and
should you beginning on the crypto
bandwagon before it's too late
[Music]
in a previous episode we talked about
how money is based on trust you trust
that this dollar has value because your
government says it does you trust your
bank when they tell you how much money
is in your account but cryptocurrency is
unique in that there are no centralized
powers no governments no banks to
enforce its value or track its
accounting instead every single Bitcoin
transaction is added to an encrypted
ledger called a block chain that is
shared publicly on thousands of
computers all over the world updating
this blockchain involves solving a
special math problem and takes a lot of
computer power Bitcoin miners who create
and update the blockchain are rewarded
for their work with shiny new bitcoins
each imprinted with the whole history of
Bitcoin transaction since the blockchain
began it's as if this dollar bill had a
written record on it everywhere it's
never been and everywhere every other
dollar bill has ever been
no one can counterfeit Bitcoin because
everyone knows exactly how much everyone
else is supposed to have your Bitcoin
wallet doesn't really hold bitcoins it's
just an encrypted key it gives you
access to however many bitcoins the
blockchain says you have which means
that unlike a bank that will give you a
new debit card if you lose yours there's
no way to retrieve a lost key one man
and the UK mistakenly threw away the
hard drive that had his key on it and
his hundred million dollars where the
bitcoins are permanently trapped in
cyberspace limo inaccessible to anyone
ever bummer
bitcoins not highly regulated and that's
made it the go-to currency first shall
we say less than savory activities drugs
prostitution and other black-market
items are regularly paid for in bitcoins
because of the pseudo anonymity it
provides according to a study at the
University of Sydney nearly half of all
Bitcoin transactions are used for
illegal activities and new crypto
currencies like Manero are growing in
popularity as they claim to be
completely anonymous but there are other
reasons why Bitcoin hasn't gone
mainstream as you've probably heard in
the news risk
it's really volatile just in the past
couple of years the price of one Bitcoin
has gone from around $500 to almost
$20,000 and then back down to around
$7,000 so even if your local coffee shop
wanted to accept Bitcoin they'd have to
constantly update the menu board prices
and because it can take pretty long to
update the blockchain your latte will
probably be cold by the time you get it
so if Bitcoin isn't really feasible as a
mainstream currency just yet
why is everyone talking about it well
most people are interested in Bitcoin
not as a currency but as a speculative
investment just like gold tulips or
beanie babies any resource that
fluctuates wildly in price will attract
people who want to get rich quick and
some people do but speculative investing
is ultra risky unlike a rental property
or a successful business Bitcoin has no
intrinsic value it's a pure gamble
hoping that you can buy the thing from
one sucker and sell it to an even bigger
sucker for more money and even though
the number of bitcoins is finite the
original programmers coated in a hard
limit of 21 million new cryptocurrency
is using blockchain or popping up every
day maybe Manero Z cash or aetherium
will ultimately overtake Bitcoin as the
most popular cryptocurrency some experts
even believe that crypto might be
adopted by government some day so if
you're thinking about investing in
Bitcoin you should ask yourself the same
things any speculative investor would do
I really understand what I'm buying and
can I afford to lose my entire
investment if the answer to either
question is no probably best to steer
clear maybe someday we'll be using
cryptocurrency to rent hoverboards on
Mars but today its popularity is based
more on its potential than its
practicality unless you're an
international criminal
in which case cut it
and that's our two cents
[Music]